this might come as a shock to you but
vice president Mike Pence said that the
president should resign over his lies
about his adultery truly shocking
revelation except he didn't say it about
the current president when I mean that
Mike Pence said the president should
resign over his lies related to
infidelity he was talking about Bill
Clinton at the time apparently when it's
Trump it no longer matters and this is
the same Mike Pence who's so pious and
so moral and so Christian such a good
Christian that he won't have dinner
alone with another woman it needs to
have a chaperone there and there's been
a bunch of old columns by pence that
have come to light and of course he's
talking about Bill Clinton here but
wouldn't it apply five times more to
Donald Trump pence wrote who knows what
year if you fall and I fall into bad
moral habits we can harm our families
our employers and our friends the
President of the United States can
incinerate the planet
seriously the very idea that we ought to
have at or less than the same moral
demands placed on the chief executive
that we place on our next-door neighbor
is ludicrous and dangerous throughout
our history we have seen the presidency
as the repository of all our highest
hopes and ideals and values to demand
less is to do an injustice to the blood
that bought our freedoms and then the
gold mine calling for the resignation of
the president for lying about adultery
not this president the previous
president of course saying our leaders
must either act to restore the luster
and dignity of the institution of the
presidency or we can be certain that
this is only the beginning of an even
more difficult time for our land for the
nation to move on the president must
move out he's also on audio visual
recordings saying very similar things
take a look at this is adultery no
longer a big deal in Indiana and in
America and just love to know your
thoughts cuz I I for one believe that
the seventh commandment contained in the
Ten Commandments is still a big deal
it's the most important promise you'll
ever make and holding people accountable
to those promises and holding people
accountable to respecting the promises
that other people make to me what what
could possibly be a bigger deal than
that in this country if
he would hold the current president to
that standard and I point this out not
to actually have a conversation about
hypocrisy but to point out that it's all
BS what I mean is political positions
public personas political issues making
something a big deal or not a big deal
this is all cover for what we've seen
happen bigger picture in the United
States for the last 30 to 40 years which
is that corporations increasingly
control government and our lives and
this is sort of the other side to the
Trump Fiasco on the one hand we have to
report on the day to day of the Trump
administration the hypocrisy from
everyone around him like Mike Pence in
this clip the lies the corruption with
Russia the possible obstruction of
justice and crimes it's all real and
it's all happening but the backdrop is
that behind the micro of the political
theater is that the Trump administration
didn't just appear out of nowhere we
have a very flawed democracy and I don't
mean just like how we count votes
first-past-the-post voting I mean our
political system for decades has been
dominated by the false dichotomy of
Democrat versus Republican when it's
been two parties that allowed corporate
power to build where the individual now
barely counts and yes all the time I
tell you Democrats and Republicans are
different on many issues what the
minimum wage should be net neutrality
important differences and we've got to
vote the current regime out in November
but elected officials from both parties
for decades stand aside
they benefit from the status quo no one
gets the corporate and dark money out of
politics and I question of course
whether any of them want to since the
status quo got them elected and then the
majority of the political debate is
playing to the narrow debate where
there's no real questioning of the
systems that got us here at large
campaign finance yes that is a meta
questioning of the system and people are
doing it some people are doing it but
not in a way where the protests and the
civil disobedience are actually going to
change what's going on how did Trump win
the Republican primary okay that's an
important question do his supporters
realize that they've been bamboozled
maybe they do maybe they don't
it matters but the big issue is how
corporate power has subjugated both
Democrats and Republicans none of that
would have changed
it's Hillary or Trump major consequences
between Hillary versus Trump which Wars
will be started how many lives will
Trump ruin but the status quo pushes
ahead and this pens hypocrisy about
resignation based on lying about
infidelity it's just another data point
that it is all political posturing 95%
of what we hear from our elected
officials on both sides is political
posturing I am thrilled to tell you that
today's episode is sponsored in part by
Blink asam / Pakman blink astiz a really
unique service for your phone tablet and
web browser and it is incredibly useful
for people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka steaks the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
YouTube I've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli nki st.com /p a que ma n